[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday september 30th
i'm kate andrews the spectators
economics editor and your host this week
on this week's show labor had their
annual conference in brighton kiyostama
was keen to prove that the days of
corbin are long gone but was
overshadowed by infighting over party
rules the resignation of a shadow
cabinet member and a debate over whether
only women have cervixes
katie balls will brief us on what
happened and paul embry and aisha
hazarica will discuss whether labour is
headed in the right and electable
direction
most brits strangely enough didn't spend
their week obsessing over the labour
party's rules for electing future
leaders a lack of lorry drivers has led
to a fuel shortage and people have been
rushing to petrol stations to fill up
their cars
it comes a few weeks after pictures of
empty supermarket shelves were plastered
on front pages
are we wrong to rely on precarious if
efficient delivery methods and as a
country are we badly prepared for a
crisis i'll speak to elizabeth brah a
security expert who sits on the national
preparedness committee
the government doesn't seem to have many
answers to the fuel crisis torres head
to manchester at the weekend for party
conference so is this a chance for boris
to reset the agenda
i'll speak to james forsyth and tory
backbencher and former cabinet minister
and duncan smith will join us too
germany went to the polls last week to
pick angela merkel's successor the
results were inconclusive and months of
painstaking negotiations between
different parties are now likely to
follow to tell us what happened and to
explain why he thinks it leaves ursula
van der lion president of the eu
commission as the world's most powerful
german politician will speak to matthew
lynn who writes for the spectator
website this week
and finally james bond is out in cinemas
this weekend daniel craig's final outing
as the spy comes in at 2 hours and 43
minutes
are films and other things just too long
i'll speak to the writer ascenda maxtone
graham who makes the case in this week's
magazine
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator tv you should subscribe to our
youtube channel just click the red
subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode
and why not subscribe to the spectator
magazine too you can get 10 weeks of the
magazine delivered to your door plus a
bottle of pims worth 25 pounds for just
10 pounds to take up the deal go to
spectator dot co dot uk forward slash tv
offer
hurry it's only available while stocks
last
and now to the show
first up labor conference was a chance
for kiyostama to show people what kind
of prime minister he wants to be but
most of the headlines were about a
shadow cabinet resignation and fighting
over rule changes was it all bad though
i'm joined now by the spectator's deputy
political editor katie balls katie
thanks for joining me you are at labour
party conference this week now the big
news for most people across the country
was the fuel crisis with all the
attention on that one might think that
labor would take the opportunity to
really get at the tories
yes it didn't quite happen like that no
it was interesting covering labour
conference now clearly uh both kirsten
and his team spend weeks perhaps even
months in advance planning the substance
of their speeches working out what they
want their main themes to be but the
fact this was also happening at a time
when most people in the country were
waking up and not sure they could get to
work how the fuel crisis is going to
affect them meant lots of the uh you
know people present at the conference
both labour mps and even international
visitors were slightly bemused it didn't
play a more central role it was
mentioned in the leaders speech but
that's the very end of conference and i
think that for example i had one
diplomat say to me not you know
particularly loaded they just simply
asked you know why didn't kiss dharma
begin conference uh filling up cars
perpetual trying to um at brighton a
petrol station and it would have gotten
lots of press now i think that you could
clearly say something like that would be
a stunt but it would get you a certain
level of exposure and i think show that
labour was part of a conversation which
uh you know is the con is the
conversation the country is currently in
and instead it just very much felt like
the labour party spent most of
conference talking to itself now
i think that in some ways i think that's
needed to get the party into the right
place to then talk to the country but it
therefore served as a reminder of how
much work labour has to do to get to the
point where it is election fit
so if labor wasn't focusing on the fuel
crisis from most of conference what were
they focused on there are a range of
things i think if you look at the
initial headlines from labour conference
it wasn't particularly what
team starman would have desired
we had a row on the first day after
angela rainer the deputy leader uh used
a speech or a reception so this was
later in the evening we can say um to
talk about tory scum
um so then there was a rao kistama's big
andrew marr interview which is supposed
to be the scene setter had to spend a
fair bit of time
with uh andrew marsk and kierstalmer if
it's appropriate to call tory's gum he
didn't but he didn't you know say that
he'd asked angela rainer to apologize um
and then we also had various trans
issues coming up um i think in that same
interview you had kids down to say that
it was wrong to say only women have a
cervix and therefore cervix was trending
on twitter quite a lot actually of the
whole conference period with lots of
events bringing that back to the fall
and then i think uh we can say the
thrust in the sense of uh what was in
stammer's control and he chose to do
anyway were the rule changes and so you
had days of you know battles internal
faction or warfare over rule changes and
particularly on
how
many people need to support a labour
leader um for for kirsten successor
taking power away from the membership
and
kirsten did win to a degree on this he
didn't get everything he wanted free but
he got a version of it um but and
therefore his team are very optimistic
about that they think it's going to mean
that they can be more bullish in the
future because labour mps are harder to
deselect it's harder to challenge
kirsten from the left but the flip side
of that is we all got to see labour's
dirty laundry played out and and the
fact that there is still plenty of
division
so in your piece for the magazine this
week you talk about the infighting that
defined labour party conference but in
terms of those fights who came out on
top is kiyosama stronger or weaker
coming out of conference
i think stamina is stronger i think the
issue is stronger and stronger two
different things that's right and we
have a situation where it's
fairly low expectations kirsten did
manage to get the upper hand on the left
of his party i think by the end of it
even those heckles during kirsten's
speech
very varied the heckling we had you know
where's peter mandelson
i think someone at one point shouted
about julian assange
um but also a big focus on the minimum
wage the fact that um
one of the dramas of labour conference
was uh that uh kirsten had a member of
shadow cabinet quit because he won't
agree to the idea of raising the minimum
wage to 15 pounds so there's a lot of
that and but i think the fact that
kirsten got through that speech and it
wasn't put off um showed that he was
standing up to that side of his party
and in a way played to his benefit
but again we do go back to the point
that he has managed to show that he is
in control of various parts of his party
but there's still that side who are out
against him and we're not yet sure what
he plans to do with that
so labor actually struggled to make a
lot of the front pages throughout their
conference and now we're going into tory
party conference from this sunday how
are labor going to continue to make
themselves relevant over the next few
weeks and make those headlines how do
they go about attacking the government
during their conference
well going back to the fuel crisis you'd
think there's plenty of things labour
could do in the coming days and weeks um
i think it is inevitably the case that
when it is a party's conference they
tend to dominate the news you for
example in the past we haven't seen many
ministers going onto the airwaves
because there's a bit of a code of
conduct there we got the other take um
center stage so i think tory conference
is clearly being dominated by the tories
and kirsten's best hope is that the
tories mess up in some way they say the
wrong thing or
the crisis around them gets worse and
that will dominate it but longer term i
think kirsten needs to work out how he
can get in on the national conversation
and that's something which um
he didn't prove at this conference yes
he made some progress but he didn't
appear reactive
able to respond to changing events in
the way that i think many in his party
would like him to be
katie thanks for joining me and i'm now
joined by the journalist and former
labor advisor aisha hazurika and the
columnist and trade unionist paul embry
hi to both of you thanks for joining
spectator tv
are you sure you wrote in your column
for the evening standard that stama had
a good week what do you mean by that
so i think it didn't start off as a good
week but i think it that that pain was
necessary to get to the end point which
was quite a good week the most important
thing that he did is that a year ago he
said that the parties under new
management
this year he proved it and that's
because he has taken on the hard left in
the party
through those rule changes the most
important rule changes are that mps now
don't have to look over their shoulder
about being de-selected by a noisy group
of marxists in their local labour
constituency parties
and the other important rule change was
that he's hopefully meant that another
jeremy corbyn or hard left candidate
will not ever be leader of the labour
party again so they're really important
things and i think his big message from
the conference speech yes there was lots
of this is who i am and there was some
sort of policy stuff but i think it was
him sending a message to the country
saying
i am not
jeremy corbyn we're not having that kind
of politics anymore and i'm moving the
labour party to the mainstream i think
the heckles were incredibly helpful for
him in fact so good they could have even
been planted it allowed him to use that
pre-scripted line saying oh on a you
know at noon on a wednesday i'm normally
getting heckled by tories and say look
you know you can chant empty slogans or
you can change lives so it allowed him
to kind of deliver those things so i
think that's the big message that's got
out however there's still such a long
way to go by no means as labour
connecting with the public yet but i
think after this conference he's at
least got the party on the pitch
paul do you agree that stamma had a good
week and is that the same thing as the
labour party having a good week
i thought he had a reasonable week um he
ended up kind of getting a score draw
out of the proposals for how we elect
the leader on future
he kind of snatched that score draw
really from the the jaws of defeat in
some respects
um i thought his speech was okay
uh i thought in delivery it was a bit
stilted a bit wooden i thought the
content was fairly good i wouldn't
really pitch it higher than that um
he
talks about the
the two rocks of his life being
family and work um i think that was a
good line um
too rarely frankly in recent years as
the labour party talks about the issues
that really matter to ordinary working
people uh and issues like family and
work essential to that he also in his
speech touched on stuff like patriotism
the importance of the armed forces
respect for the armed forces the
importance of law and order and tackling
crime um so in that respect he was
clearly pitching towards some of those
voters
who who labour have lost over recent
years
but you know the the reality is
whatever whatever kierstama thinks about
the direction of the labour party that
the labour party needs to go in and i do
think he does or he's developing a clear
idea around that
the reality is large parts of the party
simply don't want to go there and when i
say large parts i'm not just talking
about the kind of radical
corbynite left the hard left who clearly
don't like any of that kind of faith
family and flag stuff
but frankly the liberal left as well um
you know the more centrists the blair
right left who don't really do that
stuff instinctively
but probably have denounced to realize
that labour has got to speak that
language in order to win over
working-class voters and and the
mainstream um so so yes starmer i think
he's developing a clear-eyed idea of
where the party needs to go but whether
or not the party's going to go within um
remains to be seen for me there's still
a mountain to climb and i think the
party's still very much in the foothills
aisha what do you make of that i mean
the corbinises aren't going to disappear
overnight nor does the labour party
necessarily want them to completely
disappear surely they'll want them on on
polling day to show up in and vote labor
is stama trying to straddle too many
horses at one time
no i i don't think he is i think the
really noisy disruptive
difficult sort of malign elements of the
of the sort of corbin project i think
they are actually quite sort of small in
number and i think that star and his
team have been quite hard and in
cracking down in them so for example one
of the things that i really noticed was
that this year conference just the
atmosphere was much better i know there
was a little bit of heckling in the hall
but in previous years under jeremy
corbyn it has been a very very
uncomfortable quite aggressive
intimidating atmosphere at labour party
conference i know certainly people come
up to me and lots of finger pointing and
really being super aggressive somebody
spat at me once so there was there was
none of that this time yes it was not
all you know hunky-dory on the floor so
i think that the team have already been
very very clear and saying to those
people we don't want you anywhere near
the party so i don't think they feel
that they do need those um corbin people
what i think they do need though and
then and this is something that paul has
just sort of touched on you know a lot
of people in the labour party are
progressive that's one of the reasons
they're in the labour party so of course
you know he he's done this first job of
saying look we've done some kind of
hygiene on the party we've got the party
in order but he is going to have these
tensions when it comes to
policy going forward some of that will
be ideological in terms of liberal
values you know butting up against
other things a lot of those are going to
be fiscal as well we saw this big ride
with andy mcdonald over a 15 pound uh
minimum wage which look many people
would would love but what reach reeves
who had a very good conference she had a
really excellent conference she's
setting out you know some very very kind
of tough fiscal new rules for the party
she's saying no i'm not having it that
shadow ministers go out and freelance in
terms of making up policy which is
basically what was happening under
jeremy corbyn so i don't think they're
going to shed any tears about more bus
stops with kind of carbonites or more
bus stops
in terms of value for money and fiscal
responsibility but that doesn't mean
it's going to be easy there are going to
be tensions down the track in terms of
where that biting point is in terms of
balancing you know progressive labor
values with with where the the country
and might be and what might be popular
paul you've been critical of the labour
party in the past for focusing too much
on identity politics there was no
shortage of culture wars at labour's
conference this week what did you make
of it
well there hasn't been a shortage of
culture was in the labour party or on
the broader left for many years now so
so it's to be expected in many ways and
unfortunately i think because of having
immersed itself in uh in identity
politics um the the party has if you
like widened that chasm between it and
ordinary working-class voters and you
know you saw some of this stuff during
um during the conference i mean i
switched on one morning i heard a
delegate calling for rosie duffield to
to have the whitworth drawn because she
was transphobic i had another delegate
complaining that there you know were
were women-only spaces in terms of the
toilets in the conference or when you
just kind of think look if all three
people are switching onto this which
probably most of them aren't but if they
were
what would they make of this stuff the
labour party in many respects has
positioned itself on the fringe on some
of these issues and has shown that its
priorities are certainly the priorities
of large parts of the party over the
recent years are simply not the
priorities of ordinary people across
this country and
i i think the key question for labour is
this but how do they win back the red
wall how do they win back those vast
chunks of the country
which were labor since time immemorial
until 2019 but abandoned labor in their
millions provincial britain small town
britain blue collar britain these people
who
as i say would have been tribally labour
once upon a time but felt so abandoned
by the party and felt that the labour
party sneered at them and mocked them
and simply didn't want their votes
anymore and labor needs to try to to
retrieve that historic coalition um that
coalition between what i've called
hampstead and heartland for you know the
more liberal the more metropolitan white
collar voters on the one hand but also
provincial britain working class britain
blue collar britain voters with you know
soft conservative
values and views on on social and
cultural issues um and that coalition is
fragmented uh and the working class
element has simply been elbowed aside
and having felt not wanted they've gone
off and voted for somebody else so so
the key task for labor and i think this
is something that as i said before
neither the liberal left or the radical
left within the party get is you have to
start speaking the language and
reflecting the priorities of those
people you have to make a pitch to the
jillian duffy's of this world the people
who voted labor once upon a time but
were treated in the end as some sort of
embarrassing elderly relative by the
party and if anyone thinks that you know
just by talking about the armed forces
or
order are patriotism those voters are
going to come flocking back they're
going to have a rude awakening because
it has to be rooted i think in an
ideological change an internal
revolution within the party it has to be
rooted in hard policy and you have to
show through that policy development and
through language that you do understand
those voters that you are prepared to
win them back you want to win their
hearts and minds and you know the
reality is unless you do that you're
never going to win power again
ayesha last word to you by the next
election what does your gut tell you
will labor have uh continued to stay in
its comforted little bubble or will it
have branched out in the ways that paul
talks about well i mean again we haven't
talked about scotland and all of this
and you know it does actually show you
that you know
there is a place north of the the red
wall there is this place called scotland
which is really really important because
it's still part of the united kingdom
for the time being and labor is not
going to get to dining street until it
shifts more votes in scotland and
currently there are more liberal and
liberal democrat mps and pandas than
there are uh labour mps in scotland and
labour used to be absolutely dominant in
scotland particularly in the west of
scotland where i grew up where you know
the pillars of society were football
rangers and celtic the church and the
labour party in the trade union movement
so i
let the red wall is very very important
but it is not the only thing that labor
has to think about and just think about
the values that people have in scotland
as well because there is a lot of it's
very fashionable to be like oh the
labour party just you never thinks about
the north which there is i have a lot of
sympathy for but it literally doesn't
think about scotland either and kirsten
has got to shift the needle in scotland
otherwise it's it's just not going to
happen
in terms of where i think labour will be
as we run up to the next general
election i do think this week is very
important in terms of this was the
turning point where the labour party
stopped just being a complete joke and a
rabble and it began to be a serious
contender with its eyes on power instead
of just virtuous opposition
and but there is a long long way to go
kyo starmer has to get a bigger swing
than tony blair did in 1997 to just to
get a sort of majority of of one so it
is going to be really difficult but i
think he is very serious about this
really interesting looking at the
coverage today actually quite a lot of
the right wing papers are saying that
you know he he did he did a good job and
i think that's that's that's a big
moment you know to sort of be looked at
as a credible you know prime minister in
in waiting i thought the picture in the
front of the telegraph today was was you
you know money couldn't buy that picture
kia starmer with his wife looking like a
sort of normal um person sometimes those
kind of you know the partners coming up
at the end of conference could be really
really cringe for sort of a labor leader
who looked really sort of awkward about
the whole thing he does have a
confidence about him listening to him
today on the radio as well just talking
about his time as director of public
prosecution he is a serious man and we
are entering very very serious times you
know people not being able to fill their
cars up real worry about fuel bills on
the horizon food shortages like a lot of
chaos on on the horizon so while he has
got a long way to go and i would never
underestimate the campaigning juggernaut
that is boris johnson
you know if things continue to be very
very tricky and competence and planning
does get cut through with the public
then i think kia starmer
could be much more of a contender than
people have ever thought him capable of
ayushim paul thanks for joining
spectator tv
britain is in the middle of a fuel
crisis with people having to queue for
hours to fill up their cars like the
food shortages reported a few weeks ago
it stems from a lack of lorry drivers
why weren't we prepared for this and
after a year and a half of restrictions
have we learned our lessons are we
prepared for another crisis
i'm joined now by the security expert
elizabeth braw a resident fellow at the
american enterprise institute who sits
on the uk's national preparedness
committee
elizabeth thanks for joining me britain
is suffering from a fuel shortage it's
estimated that we are now 100 000 hgv
drivers short
to what extent is this an international
problem and to what extent is the
government to blame
well it's it's both uh it's an
international problem or rather a
western problem because for so many
years we've been telling
teenagers that the best thing to do in
life is to go to university and and then
we also look down on people in manual
professions so if you're a teenager why
would you ever go into a manual
profession and now we are reaping the
the fruit of that mentality and those
policies and uh so it's it's a it's a
pand western problem but the uk has been
uh one of the most active countries in
telling young people to go to university
it was the blair government but also
conservative governments and lo and
behold it turns out that that when you
look down on people in manual
professions when you tell young people
to go into academic professions then you
don't have the sort of people who make
your daily life work
well they're now offering salaries to
some htv drivers of 1 500 pounds per
week it could well be the case that
driving laurier is going to be a far
more lucrative career for the coming
months and years than it would be if you
went to university and got a so-called
white-collar job and but that hasn't
always been the case in fact it's a
recent phenomenon because we have the
shortage prices are going up um i
suppose it's quite difficult to
retrospectively prepare for that right
it's impossible um we may be attracting
people into the profession now but there
were very good reasons even a few years
ago that people might not wanted to have
trained up as lorry drivers i mean it
was becoming an increasingly difficult
career that's right and and that's why i
think you have to you as a society have
to respect the people who are in in
those jobs more and and
and companies have to pay them more
because if there are no benefits very
few benefits to being in a particular
profession why would anybody pursue it
and but i think what has become clear uh
now uh in these past few weeks and and
also during the curving pandemic is that
the the many of the professions that we
we think of as less worthy actually the
ones who make uh that make society uh uh
tick make and make it operate
efficiently um
from from nursing assistants to to
nursing home assistants to lottery
drivers to to um tesco workers all these
people are fundamentally important to to
making our society work and and i one
could even argue that people like you
and me sitting in office are more
dispensable than they are
well indeed i'm sure at least for me um
to what extent is this uh the the
public's fault consumers fault for
rushing out to the petrol station to
potentially over buy to stockpile when
there isn't actually a petrol shortage
internationally
yeah so so this is the the com the
converse wisdom of crowds when when
crowds go collectively a little bit
crazy but nobody no single driver at the
petrol station in the uk at the moment
would say well i'm panic buying now
because you never know what will happen
everybody will say oh i'm being prudent
i'm filling up so that i i don't get
stranded if things were to to get worse
and and that is that the challenge when
uh when the public is not prepared for
contingencies and i think that's why uh
some of the scandinavian countries have
lessons that that the rest of us can
learn from they try to
to prepare the public for crisis and to
make sure they don't overreact when when
there is a situation like this and as
you say there is no uh immediate
shortage of petrol at the moment but the
moment everybody keeps filling up and
filling up various reserve canisters and
so forth that's when the real shortage
uh will will occur which is what's
happening now
you're an expert in
nations building up resilience and there
have been a lot of questions recently
about the extent to which the uk was
ready not simply for covid but for any
kind of crisis that might hit and it
just seems to be one crisey after
another is part of the issue that enough
slack isn't being built into the system
to do so is expensive to essentially say
we're going to have more resources and
more capacity than we think we might
actually use but the flip side of that
is what we're seeing right now and it
isn't just petrol it's the gas shortage
in the uk it's nhs beds we could even
potentially be facing more restrictions
or indeed another lockdown this winter
if the nhs hits capacity so is that
problem the lack of slack in the system
um i think the problem is um well first
of all it's the lack of slack as you say
the lack of of redundancy capabilities
so that the model for so for for a
number of years now has been just in
time with deliveries uh taking place
constantly around the clock which makes
us extremely dependent on on global
supply chains and what happens if they
get disrupted um and then there is the
the other model which is just in case
which is i think is model we need to to
use
more and it's it's more expensive
because country companies then have to
have
extra supplies extra stock um of of the
the products that that they sell but
the problem i think is also with with
how
shareholders and boards reward ceos and
other executives for the performance
you're not at the moment you're not
rewarded as a ceo for doing just in case
you're rewarded for doing just in time
because it's cheaper but we as a society
then get into big big big trouble when
when those supplies uh are disrupted in
some way and so i think uh
as a result of covid when we saw
shortages and as a result of the truck
driver
lorry driver crisis and also as a result
i think of of shipping delays that will
cause uh other shortages i think we have
to move more towards this just in case
model and reward ceos to think who think
prudently and i think even uh it would
be even be a good idea for companies to
in their annual report
document how they are preparing for
justin just in case to show that they
are prudent and they won't be caught in
a situation where they can't provide the
service that their customers expect of
them do you think the market will
correct for this do you think customers
are now going to demand that when
they're investing with a company when
they're trusting a company to deliver
any range of product from energy to food
or whatever else that they're going to
want to know that
it will continue to be delivered in the
difficult times
i think so and uh
one and a half years ago two years ago i
wouldn't have said so i mean i've been
talking about justin in case not for a
long time and for a long time it was
difficult to make the case for it
because everything seemed to work so
smoothly but then came covered and the
realization that oh there are
disruptions uh that
that can take place that are really
serious so i think that was a collective
wake-up call that's continuing now with
these new disruptions as well and so i
think there's uh there is um uh even a
competitive advantage to be had by by
companies that prepare adequately and
and they can show the the stock market
and and their boards that they are
better prepared than other companies and
i think they'll be rewarded for it
a lot of people are saying that the
government should step in that the
government should oversee what you're
describing as a just-in-case strategy
but
my caution about that or my skepticism
is that when you look at areas that the
government has been responsible for
especially over the past 18 months we've
seen a serious lack of preparation there
i mean to what extent was the government
prepared for covet uh to what extent
where private companies prepared for
what hit us and do you think either
group the government or the private
sector have made much effort to change
their policies to prepare for the next
time that something very severe happens
well the government had tried to prepare
then
had tried to prepare and for example
conducted this
major pandemic exercise but then
very oddly put put the findings
somewhere on the shelf and didn't
implement them which was a big mistake
but i think what needs to happen is it's
not just the government that needs to
exercise for these really serious
contingencies it's the government and
the private sector collectively because
the government
is only one part of of uh the operation
of our societies and if if private
companies are disrupted if they can't
deliver the services that we as the
public and the government
rely on then uh
no government exercise will will solve
that problem or will will make um
the the crisis uh go away when it occurs
so i think what needs to happen is a
government and the private sector need
to exercise together for contingencies
from pandemics to
to shipping delays to
cyber attacks and then they are prepared
collectively if something were to happen
and then the other thing is the public
needs to be prepared so for example the
swedish government put out a leaflet a
couple years ago called if crisis of war
comes that tells people what to do in a
crisis so that they don't do what uk
drivers have been doing which is fill up
a little bit more than they need to uh
just in case so if we do all those
things i think
we'll be better prepared for for the
next crisis and there will be many of
them and they will they are inevitable
because we are so dependent on global
supply chains that are quite complex and
very long and that will have
disruptions whether we like it or not is
just the reality of of these very
complex delivery systems
elizabeth last question i wanted to pick
you up on something you just mentioned
about sweden i know you've written a lot
about preparing a population through
information campaigns
getting private companies to diversify
and and
essentially putting leaflets through
doors i think in in many circumstances
to give people the information they need
which countries are doing this well and
what exactly does that information
campaign look like
yeah so the swedish model i think is is
uh fantastic and it's by the way a model
that builds on what sweden used to do
during the cold war but it also builds
on on what earthquake zones do so i used
to live in san francisco and there were
constant public awareness campaigns
about how to prepare for earthquakes
japan does the same
citizen new zealand do the same and so
the leaflet was called if crisis of war
comes and
it describes in very simple terms as
bullet points and this is what the
crisis looks like
this is how to prepare this is what sort
of items to have at home this is how you
know that the crisis is uh is
approaching or is taking place and this
is what to do while it's happening and
this is how you know that that it's over
so very um very
easy language and as you said it was
delivered to every household in the
country because if you put it online
then people will have to get online and
consult the leaflet when the crisis is
taking place which may not be possible
so that's one model then another model
that is
is
even newer is what the czech republic is
doing and it's doing um a really
innovative thing which is
exercising or exercises involving the
armed forces and the private sector in
non-non-military scenarios so scenarios
precisely like this and they've selected
key companies in the czech republic and
and
they exercise these companies have
exercised together with the armed forces
to be better prepared for crises like
like the one we're seeing at the moment
i think that sort of concept or that
model will spread as well
elizabeth thanks for joining me
now we haven't heard much in the way of
solutions from the government on the
fuel crisis but with tory conference
starting on sunday is that about to
change
the conservatives go into their annual
meeting with a very comfortable majority
but after a difficult month following on
from the unveiling of the national
insurance tax hike to pay for health and
social care
to discuss how it will go i'm joined by
our political editor james forsyth and
tory mp and duncan smith
james anne thanks for joining me
james first tory party conference starts
on sunday but we're in the middle of
both the gas price and fuel crisis is
this a chance to reset the agenda
i think if you said this will be the
first
tory conference after the party wins an
80-seat majority you would have thought
that it would be a kind of champagne
fueled kind of victory bash but
obviously uh a lot has happened uh since
the tories won that that victory in
december 2019. and i think there's
obviously not only the kind of
short-term concerns prompted by the
petrol crisis and uh these rising gas
prices and what they mean for the winter
ahead but i also think there is that
there is that there is a bigger nagging
philosophical question bugging a lot of
tories right now which is kind of you
know what is the purpose of this
government
this government was essentially elected
in 2019 to kind of get brexit done and
keep jeremy corbyn out and it has done
both of those things now
uh you then obviously had the pandemic
which took up you know nearly all of the
government's bandwidth
and time and so now the question is you
know what is the government's post
pandemic agenda and i think that is what
they are going to need to flesh out uh
in manchester next week
and no doubt the party will be looking
backward to the victories that it had
even before the covet crisis hit but
still these these are not ideal
circumstances to be heading into the
torres party conference
well we have to say first of all that uh
kovid
is like a war
in the sense that it's knocked the
agenda of the government such as it
existed back in the end of 2019
beginning of 2020 it's knocked it
punched a hole through it really so
recovering out of kovid a year and a
half in to a government
means that we're almost starting from
scratch in a sense so this conference is
the first public conference but it's
also almost really the first conference
because everything else has been covered
so the questions that we pose is what
kind of government are we going to be as
a conservative government and i think
the range of options lies clearly but
you know sort of ted heathian government
or a margaret thatcher-style government
where you know it's a case of low taxes
and lower spending and greater booming
economy um private sector taking over so
the question really is where do we lie
on the spectrum of that and where do
those phrases
build back better and leveling up what
do they actually mean when you get to
test them in the arena of political
decision so those are the big questions
that will be posed
there are a lot of funny and strange
answers that are already coming out in
the midst of that
it's worth reminding ourselves of
mcmillan's what do i fear most
events dear boys events
and the truth is we are facing also
within all of that a set of events
postcode a lot of them coming out of
kovid which will uh almost like
earthquakes uh have seismic shocks that
go through the system you know one is
the whole failure on uh haulage drivers
because they shut down
uh every single testing center uh
stupidly during the course of covid
that's exacerbated an already existing
problem the uh
the mendacity and peculiar selfishness
of many of the haulier companies who
have invested next to nothing in their
drivers for so long uh being
torn away by cheap labor from eastern
europe all of these were meant to be
brexit questions that were settled but
we find actually brexit is still looming
in the mirror because these are still
there and they're causing us problems so
competence is critical how do we display
that we have to be free of this petrol
pump problem by the time we get to the
conference and then it's about policy
and direction and sending us off
believing that we have a purpose james
let's talk about the definitions of
these slogans because when you scroll
through the fringe guide for tory party
conference leveling up is undoubtedly
one of the most popular topics do you
think we're going to learn over the next
few days what the slogan actually means
i think the question of what is what
does leveling up mean now i think
everyone knows what it means in terms of
the long term
i think the challenges i honestly don't
genuinely i mean does it mean tax rises
which we've had does it mean um tax
breaks for you know people who are on
lower incomes uh what i have no idea to
be honest what the long-term agenda
is
long-term the aim is that every part of
a country should be as prosperous as
london and the south east that is
obviously the kind of utopian kind of
boris johnson view of what leveling up
means
i think that obviously the more
complicated question is how do you get
there
and what are the stops along the way now
boris johnson is very
he wants a very broad definition of
leveling up he thinks the fact that it
encompasses lots of things is part of
its appeal
i actually think you need a much
tighter definition of leveling up
around boosting economic growth from the
regions and devolving power down if you
i think one of the things that you see
is this is still a very centralized
country and if you look at those bits of
uh those bits of england which are
making
doing well in terms of inward investment
and the like they are often places that
have a mayor someone who can act a quran
investment there bring people together
make sure things work and i think those
i think those are should be the two
big levers that the government tries to
pull on leveling up you know which is
one of which is giving away power and
down to it down to a local level and i
think this is i mean the problem of
leveling up is at the moment is is it is
that it is in danger of becoming like
bill back better it's just in danger of
becoming a slogan that the government
attaches to everything it does
rather than a policy agenda james what
do you think the prime minister wants to
get out of his party conference
i think if you um we've interviewed
dominic rob for the magazine this week
and you know he mentioned delivery
probably more times in that interview
than any other single word you look at
the kind of click every clip boris
johnson does right now it's about
delivery i think he wants to give this
sense that the government is you know is
getting back on with stuff postcoded and
it and he's doing what it said it would
do i think that is the i think that's
what boris johnson thinks is the most
important message for him to get out of
that conference
uh i think that the challenge for him
is
uh on
you know they often talk about social
care for example and the health and
social care level is an example of
delivery
it's not yet delivery it's a decision to
raise taxes to put more money into the
nhs and to in time find more money for
social care it's not actually delivering
that new system and i think you know i
think in one of the things that in ian
said that kobe was like a war i think
one of the other things we forget is
just how much of this parliament covert
has already taken up this government is
operating on a very compressed timetable
if it wants to make visible changes to
people's lives by the next election
and and this brings us back to a point
that you raised at the start of this
discussion which is that the tories have
this big question hovering over them
what kind of party do they want to be do
they want to be more interventionist
more big state do they want to go down
eventually a lower tax route what would
you like to see from the tory party and
what are you hoping to hear at
conference
well actually now on the positive side
what uh you know we've talked a lot
about the problems but the truth is
there are some big positives for this
government if they have the energy and
the courage to seize them
we left the european union one of the
key reasons why if not almost the most
important reason why is when we say take
back control
it's about what do we believe in
regulation what's the level of
regulation that should be set the
interference in people's lives i was
asked by the prime minister to do a
report called the tigger report and it's
about what can we do to deregulate and
change and we came forward with a
significant number over 100
recommendations but more importantly to
shift the concept of regulation not to a
an absolutely over intrusive process
that says you know if anything could go
wrong we have to measure that before it
happens and actually allow as they do in
common law iterative change now that
means basically the real underpinning of
this economy is about how you make the
uk economy light on its feet
very inventive all the innovation areas
from medical tech through to uh
fight financial technology all of these
things are all there for us to grab but
we have to be bold and this government
in the next year and this is pretty much
all it's got has got to shift mountains
in terms of regulation it's got to make
sure that we are a very attractive place
the most attractive place in europe to
invest money in because we're the place
where you can build these things we can
compete with california because we know
where we're going there's no reason why
you should be governed by companies in
california need to change the rules
around gdpr allow people to take greater
control there is a whole report and it's
good that david frost is now going to
drive that through government but it
requires government ministers not to be
bound down by civil servants and to make
those changes if we do that this will
open up the british economy after kovid
and it will make us a really powerful
force for innovation all these
technologies are in existence here at a
time when we have real issues over how
we trade with china and various others
the uk could be a real hub for all of
this i would drive that now that is what
i believe
leveling up is all about because it will
bring business to areas around the uk
other than london that can actually
develop these technologies and be at the
heart of it that gives business
entrepreneurship and real rises in
salaries away from all those cheap
salaries that we thought we could pay
previously and now into serious
value-added work that we could do this
is the uk that voted to leave the
european union if we don't do that there
was no purpose in us leaving at all
leveling up is the government going to
deregulate
it has to be it has to be it's not just
i'm not talking about casualty
well david frost has now been tasked
with that and that's the one brilliant
thing that has happened i know that he's
really focused on this and a lot of
people don't understand what we mean by
deregulation it's not slash and burn
it's about resetting the whole nature of
how we look at regulation in the in the
way in which we deal for example with
common law it's about you know if we
don't know whether it's dangerous we
don't legislate for it we let ourselves
discover those things and only intervene
when it's necessary this is the whole
key to it and with that you know there
is huge areas in medical technology
which the uk is already written to lead
we could be blowing that right out the
water the same with fintech and
everything else they're right on the
cusp the uk could be that nation that
literally competes with the best in the
world but it requires us to take
advantage of leaving the european union
this is the test are we serious are we
brave are we bold and will we do it
because if we meander around in the next
year and a half trying to figure out
what we're going to do in the short term
it's not going to work leveling up and
building back better are about getting
the uk
the most flexible nation in europe and
also competing on that global state and
that requires us to shift the burden of
regulation and innovation so that we
bring businesses here to the uk
and what's the mood of the tory mps
going into party conference
well it's it's difficult you know
they're still upbeat you know we won a
big majority labor as we see in this
labor conference is still at each other
yes there's been some improvement in a
way uh in some of their rules but the
truth is labour still doesn't quite know
where it's going it still made a series
of hostages to fortune so the tories
coming into the conference will still
feel upbeat they still feel that you
know in boris they've got probably the
world's best political salesman and you
do need a good salesman at the helm but
we also need good strategy as well and
that's important but you know i think
they're still upbeat but they're they're
beginning to get concerned that we need
to see some pace on all of this and we
you know we're not the party that spends
its time rising tax raising taxes we've
got to be in the business of getting the
economy right and many of them said to
me what we need to do is treat the debt
like war debt from covid and get on to
really engineer this economy get lower
taxes get lower regulation and really
make this economy zing if we do that
we'll be able to pay back the debt at a
more accelerated pace but first let's
get the economy moving and not do things
like raising national insurance and for
things that will never happen i mean
honestly if anyone believes the health
service in three years time is going to
give back any money to social services
then i have to say they haven't been in
politics very long
james
we are getting tax rises the economy um
well we don't know if it's stagnated but
the figures from august were
extremely disappointing um
what what sense are you picking up from
tory mps is there this optimism that
that am points to or some of them
slightly more depressed
i think there is a desire for a greater
sense of what the tory party is for what
the government is for that point about
you know post-brexit postcovid what is
the government trying to do i actually
think if i was a tory mp the thing would
alarm me most this week was andrew
bailey's speech on monday evening saying
that the recovery is already weakening
uh warning about the dangers of having
to put up interest rates because of
inflation but with the economy not being
strong enough or robust enough to take
that and here's warning that these
supply and labor shortages
are are going to get worse not better
and his warning that this autumn is
going to be hard yards i mean i think
this is but i think it is that economic
backdrop but that is that is the biggest
risk of a tourist and i think as ian was
saying in one of his earlier answers you
know the government this autumn is going
to be difficult uh uh
in part because of some delayed shocks
from covid some brexit adjustments and i
think the government has to
give a sense that it is but it is in
charge but it knows what he's doing that
is not being buffeted by events
james last question to you what should
spec tv watchers be looking out for
toward tory party conference any
tensions any major moments that you
would be looking for
i i think the interesting question is is
i mean there is a a bubbling away under
the surface and it might come to the
surface given that this is the first
in-person conference in in such a long
time
is the question of you know what is the
point of the tory party um
has it become
uh
one um one senatorial said to me
recently we were elected as fat rights
we govern as goalists
has the tory party now essentially
become a goalless party or you know is
it going to go back uh
more to that that can that the
thatcherite settlement uh so i think
watch that question and then i think
also
watch to see in this debate about
the post-brexit adjustment i mean you
see this
very interestingly you know dominic rob
in this interview for the spectator this
week is very explicit you know but
basically if you were to uh issue you
know a hundred thousand visas to to
lorry drivers as as kirsten and
suggesting you know he says you know
that wouldn't solve this country's you
know um being hooked on cheap labor it
would just be a sticking past the
solution i mean the only solution he
argues is to kind of raise wages in
in all of these jobs where where firms
struggle to find
enough british workers to fill the gaps
i think that the tension between that
thinking and the desire to make sure
that christmas is uninterrupted i think
that that is going to be something that
bubbles along
at this conference and also the whole
related that the whole question of the
tory party's relationship with business
i think is going to become an
increasingly interesting question uh to
what extent you know
it should the tory party be doing what
kind of business wants in terms of
immigration the like or to what it's
censored the government be saying to
business no no you're gonna have to pay
people more invest more in training i
think those three tensions are the
things that i'll be looking out for not
no i don't you'll see that much for it
on the conference uh platform but i
think on the conference fringe those and
in the bars those will be the big
questions being debated
james and anne thanks for coming on
germans went to the polls last week to
pick who they want to be angela merkel's
successor the result was pretty
inconclusive and there are now likely to
be months of negotiations to decide who
will take charge spectator contributor
matthew lin writes on our website this
week that regardless of who comes out on
top it will be ursula van der lion who's
the most powerful german politician
around to explain matthew joins me now
now first matthew can you remind us in
layman's terms what happened in the
german elections for those of us that
haven't been following along as closely
as you
uh well it was it was kind of a four-way
draw
at the end of the day i mean no one got
anything close to a commanding majority
the social democrats which is the german
version of the labour party i guess you
know just about came it came in front
with 25 percent of the vote the cdu
angela merkel's party the conservative
party you know the dominant force for
last 20 years or so a very disappointing
result 24
or so the vote the greens did pretty
well but not as well as they were doing
in the polls uh a few months ago they
did 14 and and slightly oddly named free
democrats they're sort of they're not
like the liberal democrats they're a
sort of um pro we don't have anything
quite like it in this country that kind
of pro free market um pro business party
uh they scored about 11 and then there
was the far right afd on about 10
percent so it was just a completely you
know completely inconclusive result i
mean you know the spd came ahead but by
such a whisker no one was close to no
one was close to a real majority
and they're going to have to cobble
together some kind of coalition uh with
a chancellor but whoever that person is
they're just not going to have a huge
degree of public support
so is it right then to say that the most
powerful german politician whoever the
next chancellor is is not going to have
a really strong mandate
yeah no i think i mean i think that's
absolutely true like you know anyone who
if you poke 25 percent in a general
election you can't come out of it and
say you have a tremendous mandate you
know three quarters of the electorate
voted for somebody else and
and and weren't looking for you it's a
very very fragmented probably you know
much closer to an italian system than
the traditional german system and
traditionally germany you know was a big
two-party system uh much like the uk
with sort of you know smaller parties uh
a bit like the lib dems in this country
on about sort of five to ten percent of
the vote and that's completely gone i
mean it's a four it's a four to six
party system uh and that tends to be
very unstable i mean in the past the
past 10 years or so angela merkel's held
it together uh but it'd be a mistake to
assume that her successor can do the
same
well yes you slightly preempted me there
because i'm wondering what this means
for domestic policy and indeed foreign
policy for germany is there going to
have to be a lot of compromise
historically our german party's good at
compromising to get some kind of policy
over the line or is it going to be a
stalemate i think it'll probably be a
stalemate i mean you know the most
likely coalition you see you'll see at
the moment is is the social democrats
and the greens and the free democrats um
it's it's hard to see really what those
three parties have in common apart from
the fact that they're not they're not
the christian democrats you know you
have a kind of traditional fairly old
school sort of trade union-dominated
labor-type party
you know you have a very radical
ecological party and a kind of
pro-business party it's going to be it's
going to be a mess and i think the
interesting thing is it's going to be
very unstable
it's going to be unstable you couldn't
guarantee that the government will
survive because it'll be three parties
um so it's only going to be you know one
crisis away from somebody thinking oh
actually i'm going to pull out of this
i'm going to precipitate an election so
then you're going to have instability um
and secondly uh you're not gonna have
much clarity of policy uh policy i don't
think you're gonna see any kind of clear
leadership coming out of germany i mean
you know the critics of angela merkel's
the long 16-year reign she
she kicked the can down the road um and
she postponed any kind of problem and
she avoided hard decisions um but you
know you'll probably look back on that
as a kind of golden era of german
politics of a decisiveness uh compared
to what the next four years are going to
be like
well very optimistic matthew
you write in your piece for coffeehouse
this week that the real winner of the
german elections is the eu commission
president ursula van der lion can you
explain yeah absolutely i mean i think i
think that flew on the radar a little
bit but you know a couple of points i'd
make there um you know what i think
actually you know wonderland is going to
emerge as the most powerful german
politician you know she's going to have
this very weak chancellor in berlin
which is big contrast to you know to
merkel who uh whatever her domestic
problems you know she was a commanding
figure her success was not going to be a
commanding figure at all for for all the
reasons we just discussed uh whereas you
know wonderland you know she
you it's a funny body she hasn't had a
great track record of success so far uh
particularly on the vaccines but that's
not really relevant that doesn't really
matter in brussels uh whether anything
actually works or not um she's you know
she can be very powerful she can be very
decisive you know it's um
you know the commission has a lot of
power she can get up and launch
initiatives and and spend money and do
things that she's going to make you know
by she's going to be by far the most
powerful uh german politician and i
certainly wouldn't discount you know her
kind of returning to berlin in four
years
to save the christian democrats and and
bring them back to power but i think the
second thing that's interesting apart
from my personal standing is just how
much power uh the commission is
accumulating for itself it's kind of
flying under the radar because you know
they're doing it they're doing it by
stealth um it's a bit like you know in
this country gordon brown used to
increase taxes in the size of the state
a lot but he he did something quite
clever which he's never told anyone
about it
and that kind of helped because he felt
if he told anyone about it
there might be some opposition and if
you look at what the eu's actually doing
you know it's having a huge increase in
power it's taking control of health
policy uh which as we know uh in you
know in every country in the western
world when you control health policy you
control pretty much everything
especially in a pandemic
the coronavirus rescue fund is a huge
increase in economic power um it had its
own budget it has its own debt and it
has control of national budgets and
spending and spending powers and if you
look at the rule of law conflicts with
hungary and poland it's taking control
of constitutions as well
so that's you know probably the biggest
increase in powers for the eu commission
since the launch of the single currency
and probably even bigger
and that and you know and vandalian's
been good at pushing that forward and
without much opposition in berlin but
you know merkel and with the most
powerful local politician national
politician putting a break on that and
saying no you know not too much power
keep powering the national governments
um very hard for anyone else standing up
to it the french are very enthusiastic
so are the italians so all the big you
know the two other big states
will be in favor of increasing that kind
of federal uh overreach and germany will
probably not be in the position to
oppose it
well matthew let me ask how is the eu
trying to centralize healthcare that
strikes me as really quite a big deal
surely they would have learned their
lessons through vaccine procurement
which went so badly at the start of the
year that that is perhaps not something
that brussels should be doing and should
absolutely be devolved to smaller states
i mean to what extent are they really
trying to bring health care into
brussels oh well you know i think i
think that's clearly the case yeah i
mean that you know they're they're
they're bureaucrats and technocrats you
know they don't they don't let little
things like
like success or failure get in the way
why you know why should they what's that
what's that what's that got to do with
it um you know it's it's it's a it's a
bureaucratic technocratic organization
and we know from experience that they
like to increase their power why you
know why wouldn't they um like any or
like any organization so they took
control of vaccine policy um
and you know it wasn't a great success
but you know they kind of got there in
the end um and you can argue about you
know
about the decisions that were made but
they're now saying their line is that it
was a success and they're and and
they're keeping control of vaccines and
and they're moving further vaccines give
them a kind of wedge i think to take
more and more control of health policy
matthew to sum up it sounds like you're
saying that a a weaker germany or
germany that can't provide that check on
power to the eu naturally means that
brussels is going to be stronger but
isn't a weak germany still bad for the
eu overall
absolutely i mean it's bad it's bad for
the european economy i mean i think
that's very true and i mean you know i'm
saying it'll it'll increase the power of
the uh
the commission in brussels and i think
that's just an observation
if we're going to say is that a good
thing well no i don't think it is
because you know just coming back to
your earlier point if you look at look
at health policy uh and many other
aspects of policy it's actually much
better to to control that at a more
local uh national level
but the reality is that the commission
is increasing its power and you know the
other countries in europe are going
along with that but yeah absolutely no i
mean a weak germany is not good for it
is not good for europe the rest of
europe and that includes the uk because
in germany it's a rich successful
country it can it can be in
modest sort of stagnation uh for a heck
of a long time without anyone really
minding but it you know it has it has
that's quite a lot of problems it's over
reliant on the car industry it's over
reliant on exports uh it's absolutely
nowhere in the digital industries you
know the extraordinary statistics 44 of
german companies still use fax machines
um you know most people are like what
exactly is a fax machine still where do
you plug it in how does it work um it's
it's got a lot of problems which are
built up i mean the merkle years have
been
you know described i think quite
accurately as you know years years of
stagnation but that's going to be on
roller skates that's going to really
speed up that's become much more the
case you know i think um you know
in retrospect she's going to look fairly
good compared to what comes next the
coalition that's likely to emerge uh in
the next two or three months will be
less decisive uh and will have less
power
and certainly won't be interested in any
kind of
i i was about to say radical economic
reform but that would be way over the
top even modest economic reform i think
will be will be off the agenda
i think the national health service also
uses a disproportionately high number of
fax machines
decide what to make of that yeah not
something you usually want to emulate
for efficiency and modernity and forward
thinking well that's a whole different
conversation thanks matthew
and finally the new james bond film hits
the cinemas this weekend it comes in
however at 2 hours and 43 minutes is
that too long
ascenda maxtone graham writes in this
week's magazine that it's part of a
trend of films plays and speeches
dragging on she joins me now ascenda
thanks for coming on you write in the
magazine this week that films among many
other things are just too long these
days why do you think that
well i do wonder whether after our
lockdown habits of tucking up to one
hour-long episode every evening of the
netflix drama we're currently addicted
to
whether we can really cope with this 2
163 minute bond film it i have just now
booked for sunday afternoon i'm already
slightly dreading a third of a third of
a day being taken up watching this thing
and just wonder whether
those days
of
the public being able to happy to
surrender themselves in the dark in a
criminal captive situation are over
so do you think that the snappiness of
netflix and amazon shows have
essentially ruined our attention span
well i wonder i mean although some
people could say that the 62 episode
long breaking bad for example is
actually the most bloated form of art
imaginable in fact far more bloated than
163 minute film um but i suppose the
great thing about that is you can get up
and make a cup of coffee in the middle
of it you can press
pause you can press watch next episode
um i wonder if this james bond film had
a watch next episode on the r every hour
we might be able to we might be more
happy to cope with it it's just that
sort of sprawlingness of it that i'm i
feel rather nervous about that for
sunday i've got to go at the 2 o'clock
hoping to be out by my cup of tea at 10
past five but yeah that's a long time
well somebody who adored but also binge
breaking bad i i did watch it with a
friend and so we would pause and talk
about it and maybe that was
subconsciously our attention span saying
we need to take a small break but what
you're saying is that we we need that
little bit of space in between a really
long program and and and being able to
do other things so it's more about just
getting up getting that cup of coffee
you think then actually people's desire
to have something like a film or a story
uh go on for a really long time
yes although i do think i've talked
about time empathy in in the piece
that's what really what it's about it's
about the creator of the art um the
people work about i think really
imagining himself in the audience's
shoes perhaps an audience who needs to
go to the loo um and how you know how
much longer do they really could they
not cut that bit could they not cut that
lingering shot that reaction shot could
they not just trim it and sometimes i
wonder about the self-indulgence of
these people who really are so in love
with their creation they cannot cannot
cut it well yes i was going to ask about
that too is there an issue of
self-indulgence here that perhaps
this two and a half three-hour film
isn't being made for the audience is
being made for the director
well that is that is where i am and do
you remember being sitting through
gandhi in the 1980s i mean and and guys
for gone with the wind i mean you know
these have been some of the most long
afternoons of my my life and i i i do i
always do think about the
self-indulgence aspect of it um and i
talk about plays as well
um you you really have to
you you have to keep an audience on your
side and and that people never want i
mean never want that something to be
longer never well
do you mention shakespeare in your piece
does this apply to him too
yes i know that's a bit bit naughty
really to start taking up taking
shakespeare on for exact falls but i
must say looking at anthony cleopatra
act forum and i can really do without it
[Laughter]
don't get off
of course the flip side of this so i've
i've booked my bond ticket for saturday
i can't wait to go i see going to the
cinema and and specifically going to the
cinema not just watching a film as an
opportunity to turn off my phone put it
away and actually have a bit of respite
from the rest of the world so sometimes
i'm sitting there thinking the longer
the better
well in a way that's true um
but it's going to be very very exciting
to be in this in this room i hope it's
going to be full in spite of the petrol
crisis with um people actually there
together gasping and watching and that
is something we still still long to do
um i'm just hoping that i'm certainly
not going to have a glass of water
before it um and
try not to have too much popcorn so i
didn't get too thirsty in the middle and
i'm hoping goodness i can make head or
tail of it sometimes there's such a
sprawling messes these films i can't
even understand what's going on
so you've said you have booked your bond
ticket as well so you haven't been put
off completely by the time but let me
ask you finally are there any films or
plays that you do think warrant that
longer running time the godfather part
one for example is nearly three hours
lord of the rings films of course um
were something like three hours long
each um but really incredible cinema yes
you're absolutely right and there are
there are some that could not be short i
mean i'm sticking with the tragic mode
of showa the the holocaust movie which
needed to be that that that long um and
and some things are i talk about in the
piece i talk about appropriate lengths
and i do say i i
that's the question appropriate natural
length and things do have a natural
length i mentioned test matches which
are five days long um that does seem
right what i don't like is bloatedness
and um self-indulgence sort of um
taking too long over over shots and over
scenes too much talking talking talking
just cut it
acinda thanks for coming on
and that's it for this week if you
enjoyed the episode don't forget to
subscribe to the spectator's youtube
channel so you never miss out just click
the subscribe button at the bottom of
this video and tap the bell icon to make
sure you never miss an episode
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you